la dernière fois on a parlé des espaces
de très grandes dimensions et on a vu
que ces espaces étaient hyper bizarre et
en pratique ça fait que le machine
learning a de bonnes chances d'échouer
quand il s'agit d'analyser des données
de très grandes dimensions comme du
texte du son ou des images on parle de
la malédiction de la dimensionnalité
pour lutter contre la malédiction de la
dimensionnalité il est utile de chercher
à résumer la complexité des données
brutes en une représentation de moindre
dimension on parle de réduction de la
dimension une alitée ou encore même s'il
ya pas vraiment un consensus là dessus
d'apprentissage de la sémantique la
sémantique en ce sens c'est un vecteur
de petites dimensions qui résume bien
l'information contenue dans une donnée
brute dont la dimension est très grande
à prendre la sémantique des données
brutes ça correspond donc à transformer
tout vecteur de grande dimension en un
vecteur de dimensions plus petites
et on verra dans le prochain épisode qui
étrangement la sémantique apprise par
des intelligences artificielles n'est
pas si distincte du sens intuitif qu'on
attribue habituellement à la sémantique
et oui ça veut aussi dire que via le
machine learning
on est en train de donner un sens à la
sémantique c'est énorme
inception aujourd'hui on va parler de
deux approches classiques de cet
apprentissage des scènes antiques appelé
analyse par composante principale ou à
cp ainsi que cindy leur value des
compositions ou svd alors attention une
fois de plus notamment pour ceux qui
n'ont jamais fait d'algèbre linéaire ça
va piquer un petit peu et vous n'allez
sans doute pas tout comprendre mais je
pense qu'il ya moyen de retenir les
grandes idées et puis c'est peut-être là
un moyen de trouver la motivation pour
vous attaquer à l'algèbre linéaire
bref commençons par la cp imaginons donc
un espace de figure de grande dimension
et plein de points dans cet espace
l'aspect consiste à identifier les
bonnes façons de tourner cet espace pour
y voir les principales variations du
nuage points voilà qui permet d'ignorer
direction selon lesquelles les
variations sont en fait négligeable
plus concrètement imaginons que nuages
de points à la forme d'une assiette
alors il sera en fait essentiellement un
espace de dimension 2 quand bien même il
vit dans un espace de dimension 3 la cp
va alors identifié cet espace est
projeté tous les poids du nuage sur le
plan du disque
dès lors quand on représente la
projection du nuage de points dans le
plan du disque on voit les principales
variations du nuage de points en
particulier nommé ainsi celles qui sont
négligeables
alors bien sûr là je donne le cas d'une
projet
on d'un nuage de points de dimension 3
sur un plan de dimension deux parce que
c'est plus facile à visualiser mais les
utilisations dacp qui sont vraiment
incontournable c'est davantage quand
l'espace des features et de dimensions 1
millions et qu'on projette sur un hyper
plan de dimension beaucoup plus petit
disons 100 ou plus généralement ça
permet de passer d'un espace de
dimension t à un espace de dimension
c'est beaucoup plus petit et l'astuce
est alors en gros la même
elle consiste à identifier les
directions de plus grandes variations du
nuage de points
les composantes principales et ensuite
effectuer une projection orthogonale sur
l'hyper plan engendrés par ces
composantes principales pour ceux qui
veulent plus de détails techniques
sachez qu'il s'agit d'une projection sur
la base orthonormé des vecteurs propre
de la matrice de covariance qui a le bon
goût d'être symétrique et je vous
renvoie vers une vidéo de we need a pour
plus de détails en particulier d'un
point de vue âgés briques effectuer une
prédiction orthogonale revient à garder
en mémoire seulement les ses composantes
principales parmi toutes les directions
des voix là on vient de réussir à
résumer toute la complexité d'un nuage
de points pour apprendre une
représentation sémantique des données et
de façon cruciale
cette représentation sémantique n'est
que deux dimensions c'est ça ce qu'on
appelle la réduction de la
dimensionnalité et ça permet d'éviter la
malédiction de la dimensionnalité ainsi
que le fléau de la surinterprétation
dont on a déjà longuement parlé dans les
vidéos précédentes
dès lors ce lord astuce il consiste à
tourner les données albi lui et de sorte
à avoir des composantes principales et
des composantes négligeable qu'on va
ensuite est négligée c'est quelque chose
que l'on retrouve dans beaucoup de
problèmes notamment dans la compression
de données que sont les formats jpeg mp3
ou autres h 264 c'est pour la vidéo et
je vous renvoie notamment vers
l'excellence vidéo des logiques qui
parle des séries de fourier pour en
savoir plus aujourd'hui
la cp est devenu un outil incontournable
utilisé partout dans l'industrie pour
analyser mais aussi pour représenter
visuellement les données oui parce que
c'est plus facile de représenter sur 1
pol pot est une représentation graphique
des données de dimension 2 que des
données brutes et de dimensions 1
million en particulier la cp permet
ainsi d'identifier les caractéristiques
distinctives d'un jeu de données alors
il y aurait quelques bémols à mettre à
la cp notamment le fait que la cp n'a de
sens que si les dimensions sont
comparables
en termes d'unités il faut en
particulier éviter de comparer des
pommes et des bananes ou encore les
nombres d'années d'existence d'une
chaîne youtube et leur nombre de vues
bref si je résume la cpc prendre un
nuage de points dans un espace de grande
dimension d et le projeter dans un seul
espace de plus petites dimensions c'est
dans lequel on verra néanmoins très bien
les variations entre les ponts du nuage
de points peut maintenant passer à sbds
vd où cindy leur value 10 composition
fut l'un des algorithmes clé pour
remporter le prix netflix dont on
apparaître dans l'épisode 17
le problème en question était le suivant
on a tout plein d'utilisateurs et tout
plein de films et certains films ont été
notés par certains utilisateurs par
exemple monsieur fille a adoré black
mirror ljg à apprécier cube et eurêka
regarde religieusement de big short tous
les soirs avant de se coucher
le problème du prix netflix consiste
alors à masquer certaines de ses notes
et à deviner les notes masqué à partir
de celles qui ont été révélées pour
résoudre ce problème l'astuce de sgd
consiste à imaginer que chaque
utilisateur est une nouvelle direction
dans un espace de grande dimension du
coup si on a un million d'utilisateurs
l'espace des utilisateurs sera de
dimension un million dès lors chaque
film pourra être localisés dans cet
espace en considérant que la note qu'un
utilisateur accorde un film elle a
coordonné du film dans l'espace des
utilisateurs en traitant tous les films
de la sorte on obtient un nuage de
points représentant les films dans
l'espace des utilisateurs svd consiste
alors à appliquer la cp à ce nuage de
points
autrement dit svd va chercher la bonne
façon de regarder l'ensemble des films
dans l'espace des utilisateurs de sorte
à détecter les principales variations
d'appréciation des films par les
utilisateurs
une remarque que l'on peut faire c'est
que la direction selon laquelle le nuage
de points des films varie
particulièrement beaucoup correspond à
des variations importantes des types
d'utilisateurs et cette variation des
types d'utilisateurs correspond
d'ailleurs aussi à une variation des
types de films en particulier cette
direction de plus grandes variations
n'est pas complètement déconnecté de ce
que l'on pourrait penser intuitivement
typiquement ça pourrait correspondre à
la violence des films et à
l'appréciation de la violence par les
utilisateurs
l'intensité des variations de
l'appréciation de la violence par les
différents utilisateurs est alors
appelée valeur singulière de là
violence on peut ensuite identifier
d'autres directions orthogonale de
grandes variations d'appréciation des
films qui pourra correspondre à d'autres
notions intuitives comme par exemple à
ce que le film est un film romantique un
film de super héros ou une comédie svd
va ensuite chercher à caractériser un
nombre restreint ses deux composantes
principales du nuage de points de films
dans l'espace des utilisateurs en
ignorant ainsi les autres directions
selon lesquelles les variations
d'appréciation des films sont faibles ce
qui revient géométriquement à projeter
les films dans un seul espace de
composantes principales des films on
obtient alors une importante réduction
de la dimensionnalité ce sous espace de
projection
c'est ce qu'on pourrait être appelée
l'espace et sémantique film utilisateurs
et alors que la dimension de l'espace
des utilisateurs est typiquement deux
dimensions un million c'est à dire le
nombre d'utilisateurs l'espace des
sémantique lui pourraient être des
dimensions beaucoup plus faible disons
c'est égal sens et ça c'est super cool
parce que ça permet de combattre le
problème de lover fitting alors je parle
bien des espaces de sémantique film
utilisateurs parce que non seulement
tout filmer quelque part dans cet espace
de sémantique mais c'est aussi le cas de
tout utilisateur
en effet souvenez vous l'espace des
sémantique est un sou espace de l'espace
des utilisateurs et chaque utilisateur
est une direction de cet espace des
utilisateurs en projetant orthogonale
mans le vecteur unitaire qui représente
un utilisateur temps le sou espace d
sémantique on obtient une représentation
sémantique de l'utilisateur dans
l'espace filmé utilisateurs ainsi chaque
film mais aussi chaque utilisateur est
quelque part dans l'espace de sémantique
et la note d'un utilisateur pour un film
données sera égal au produit scalaires
entre le vecteur qui représente
l'utilisateur est le vecteur qui
représente le film
mais surtout
cela pour effectuer des prédictions pour
les notes que recevra un nouveau film
disons le film est ta gueule letters
en effet le fait d'avoir identifié un
espace de ces antiques de dimensions
sans seulement fait que seulement 100
données sont nécessaires pour localiser
le film en question dans l'espace et
sémantique en particulier c'est un
utilisateur 10 on les attribue une note
de 3 étoiles au film et aegon letters
alors on saura que dans l'espace des
sémantique ou léa est représenté par un
vecteur le film nine network correspond
un déplacement de trois unités selon la
direction les a il sera donc quelque
part orthogonale à trois unités
selon l'air vous pouvez alors imaginez
que plus on dispose de notes de films
plus on pourra préciser les positions
possibles du film dans l'espace des
sémantique et quand on aura autant de
notes que la dimension de l'espace des
sémantique on sera où exactement se
trouvent être à gauche l'intérieur dans
l'espace de sémantique film utilisateurs
une fois ce film localiser on pourra
ensuite prédire la note qu'un autre
utilisateur va probablement attribué au
film tout simplement en prenant le
produit scalaires entre le vecteur du
film est le vecteur de l'utilisateur
pour tous ceux qui ne sont pas super à
l'aise avec ces notions de points de
vecteurs et de produits scolaires
je vous renvoie vers les vidéos - dida
il espère que vous êtes motivés pour les
voir bref grâce à svd on a réussi à
construire un espace de sémantique film
utilisateurs et à exploiter cet espace
pour effectuer des prédictions
et le plus fou c'est que ça marche ces
manipulations des espaces de grandes
dimensions sont au fondement de l'un des
meilleurs algorithmes de machine
learning d'aujourd'hui à tel point
qu'ils ont contribué à résoudre le
challenge netflix et qui font désormais
sans doute partie des algorithmes que
nous utilisons quotidiennement sur
netflix sur youtube avant de revenir à
vos commentaires de la vidéo présente
une petite annonce je serai à
vulgarisateur le samedi prochain le
samedi 28 avril et je serai en très
bonne compagnie puisque il y aura aussi
blake tabasse eureka ma nombril et
lanternes cosmique et en particulier moi
ce dont je vous parlerai c'est d'un truc
un petit peu malaisien parce que vous
parlerait d'un mouton noir d'un cygne
noir et d'un corbeau noir mais parfois
on a parlé de l'espace de très grande
dimension avec ali j ai radio nous
demande si l'intuition géométrique est
vraiment utile à développer dans ce
genre de cas finalement très vite perdu
en pratique quand on fait des calculs
par rapport à tout ça en un an la
tendance à ramener très rapidement tout
ça à des manipulations purement
algébrique avoir des équations et des
manipulations de nombre alors très
clairement si vous voulez vraiment être
à l'aise avec tout ça au bon moment
faudra passer par ces manipulations
algébrique parce que c'est avec ça qu'on
touche vraiment la rigueur de ces
espaces de très grandes dimensions et
qu'on est vraiment capable de savoir si
ce que j'ai dit dans la vidéo présente
par exemple est vrai ou pas mais je
pense néanmoins qu'il est extrêmement
utile du que personnellement il m'a été
extrêmement utiles même au niveau de la
recherche de chercher à constamment
avoir une intuition géométriques autant
que possible de ses espaces de très
grandes dimensions de ces différents
objets de très grande dimension
typiquement un truc important sur lequel
j'ai pas vraiment cité dans vidéos
précédentes parce que c'est pas
forcément un truc vraiment mais c'est un
truc pour moi qu'il faut retenir c'est
qu'en fait un hypercube une hypercube de
très grande dimension
c'est quelque chose de très grands
notamment la grande diagonale de
hypercube a une taille qui est égale
racine carrée 2d et du coup toutes les
dimensions typique à l'intérieur du cube
sont de l'ordre de racine carrée de
deuil c'est pour ça qu'un hyper cubes de
côté 1
en fait très très grand on dimensions 1
milliard en fait ça correspond à un
objet dont à distance typique entre deux
points est de l'ordre de racine carrée
de 1 milliard
c'est ce genre d'intuition qui est quand
même l je pense en fait extrêmement
utile à voir dans les espaces de grandes
dimensions et un autre truc que je
trouve très important c'est qu'il ya
certaines intuitions qu'on a pour les
espaces de petite dimension parce qu'on
est habitués et en a certaines qui se
généralise pas du tout du coup c'est
important de les oublier quand on passe
au camp dimension mais on a d'autres qui
se généralise à ses biens notamment
pendant que le théorème de pythagore
qui en fait est un théorème j'en ai
parlé dans une vidéo - didot et ça se
trouve très facilement présence de très
grandes dimensions et mais c'est aussi
très pertinent par exemple pour parler
de la cpu ou dvd puisque la notion d'
orthogonale it et en particulier est
fondamentale et de projections
orthogonale est fondamental pour tous
tous ces raisonnements et ce qui est
assez fou c'est que cette intuition
géométriques que l'on a peut permettre
de raisonner plus vite d'aller plus
rapidement dans certains raisonnements
et d'avoir une intuition assez rapide
sur la bonne manière de procéder pour
résoudre un problème est ensuite faut
quand même formaliser sa essayer de se
ramener à l'algèbre à chaque fois pour
pouvoir effectivement résoudre le
problème mais par opposition si on
commence directement avec l'âge est vrai
qu'on essaie de manipuler purement
notation et givry pour en arriver à un
résultat
bah finalement c'est souvent assez
difficile d'en arriver au but puisque on
n'a pas une vision d'ensemble c'est un
peu difficile d'anticiper verrou ça va
aller c'est pour ça que je pense que
l'intuition géométrique est en fête
importante à développer pour raisonner
sur ces espaces de très grandes
dimensions n'a été une drague nous
devons du coup comment est-ce qu'on peut
visualiser c est pire qu et ses espaces
et hyper ce faire ces objets de très
grande dimension
mais à la fin c'est que c'est pas facile
c'est tout d'abord on va pas avoir une
vision purement complète de ces objets
je pense que la bonne façon de penser le
truc c'est qu'on va essayer de voir
certains bouts on va avoir une intuition
de certains morceaux de ces différentes
structures géométriques de très grande
dimension
on ne voit pas les voir dans leur
entièreté mais c'est d'ailleurs le cas
également quand on pense à des objets de
dimension 3 si vous y réfléchissez il ya
plein de structures 10 mois sont trois
qui sont en fait affreusement complexe
et qui nous est impossible de penser
dans leur globalité et puis même en
dimensions de deuil à dire des trucs à
faire et c'est troublant et on a
tendance à voir juste certains morceaux
et puis a essayé de recoller un petit
peu les morceaux je pense que c'est un
petit peu comme ça qu'il faut qu'on sait
les espaces de très grands
dimensionnement et les objets de ces
espaces de très grande dimension
voilà on essaie de comprendre certains
morceaux et puis voir une compréhension
partielle de différents partis de ces
objets extrêmement complexe bon mais
clairement on peut pas espérer les
visualiser dans leur entièreté en
particulier à sur ip refaire il y à des
vidéos d'alain bernard que je vous
recommande vivement donc aller les voir
ça permet de se faire une petite idée de
ces espaces de dimensions 4 je suis pas
si parmi dimension 5
après ça reste à la dimension 4 ou 5
pour les espaces de dimension un million
c'est encore quelque chose de très très
différents que l'on compte par des
espaces de grandes dimensions vacances
et 4 ou 5 mais les objets d'étude d'une
machine learning c'est des objets de
dimensions 1 millions voire en milliards
et c'est souvent des trucs encore un peu
plus bizarres sur lequel on va voir des
intuitions encore beaucoup plus
partielle mais même les intuitions
partiel sont souvent extrêmement utile
enfin qui regarde me demande si avec
d'autres normes ne peut pas avoir des
trucs plus intuitif
alors pour comprendre cette question
déchire il faut comprendre un peu la
notion de norme qui avait un petit peu
mentionné dans l'épisode 18 de façon
purement algébrique la norme
en fait c'est pour mesurer la taille en
fait un vecteur qui a des coordonnées à
la manière de tout mesure la taille de
cet objet une façon de faire donc a
énormément ce qu'il y de faire dans ce
cas c'est de prendre la somme des
valeurs absolues des coordonnées
effectivement un grand vecteur c'est
qu'un vecteur qui va voir des
coordonnées très grande du coup c'est
une bonne façon de mesurer la taille du
vecteur la norme 2 c'est ce qu'on
appelle la norme euclidienne aussi parce
qu'elle est conforme avec l'inventeur de
pythagore c'est celle qu'on a utilisées
en fait pour parler des perceurs je
parlais de distance en fait c'est
intuitif mans cette notion de pain c'est
la notion de norme 2 c'est à dire que la
norme 2 d'un vecteur des dimensions 2d
ça va être la racine carrée du de la
somme des carrés de ses coordonnées
ensuite on peut peut-être parlé d'un
énorme infinie énorme infinie c'est la
norme qui mesure
à plus grande des coordonnées en valeur
absolue c'est le maximum des valeurs
absolues des coordonnées et puis à
d'autres normes notamment les normes
paix pour payer en toi et l'infini ah
oui aussi la norme zéro dont j'ai parlé
dans l'épisode 18 mai à norme zéro en
fait c'est pas une norme au sens où
elles mesurent pas vraiment spagnou peut
elle pas toutes les bonnes propriétés
qu'on aimerait que les normes est du
coup on parle parfois de semis norme
n'est ce pas vraiment énorme
on peut l'oublier pour aujourd'hui en
tout cas bref tous ces objets sont des
façons de mesurer les tailles d'une
flèche toutes les tailles d'un vecteur
et on peut aussi mesurer la distance
entre deux points de l'espace regardant
la norme du vecteur qui lie de la flèche
qui va d'un point à l'autre
ici on choisit chacune de ces
définitions on obtient du coup une
définition différente de la distance et
du coup d hyper sphères différentes
en gros du père se faire et ne soit ni
perceur dépend de la norme que vous
considère dans vidéos précédentes j'ai
prié du coup il perd son père qui
correspondait à la norme 2 est en fait
ce qui se passe c'est que si on prend
l'hyper serre qui correspond à la norme
1 on obtient un espèce de hyper oct à l
ess est hyper aux cadres en fait il va
être plus petit que l'hyper sphère de
norme 2 mais alors si vous ne trompe pas
lâcher en train d'utiliser mon intuition
géométriques l'ajustement si je me
trompe pas il va pas être énormément
plus petit que l'hyper serre qu'ils y
perdent particulier l'intérieur va pas
être avare rhume qui va être énormément
plus petit que l'hyper boulot ce cas la
comparaison sera pas comparable à celle
entre l'hyper bull et hypercube l'hyper
suaire de la norme infinie ça va être
hyper kummer en l'occurrence donc hyper
se faire pour un énorme infinie est
quelque chose qui a un grand volume oui
parce que dans la vidéo présente si j'ai
parlé de volume et à la notion de volume
et pas aliénation des normes jusqu'aux
la notion de volume on peut la ramener
ça son essai de découper les pièces
est-ce qu'on peut les faire rentrer dans
une autre et je vous renvoie vers une
vidéo d'hadji pour en savoir plus pour
le cas de la dimension 2 et 3 donc voilà
en fonction de la norme que choisissez
vous obtenez une des finales différentes
pour l'hyper bull après la norme 2 est
assez naturel et pour une autre raison
c'est que en fait elle correspond à des
symétries 2
nos rotations j'ai pas mal parlé
notamment c'est l'épisode sur la cps vd
le fait de tourner l'espace en fait le
fait de tourner l'espèce ça se définit
mathématiquement par fait d'avoir sont
pas des matrices orthogonale qui sont
capables de tourner espace une certaine
symétrie en fait qui corresponde à ses
ces mouvements de rotation en hausse ans
est en gros quand on tourne l'espace
comme ça les notions de nos mains et de
normes infinie vont complètement changer
c'est à dire que si je prends un vecteur
et que je le tourne alors sa norme va
changer ce qui peut paraître assez
bizarre la norme qui est cohérente avec
cette histoire de rotation c'est en fait
la norme de la norme euclidienne pour ça
que c'est un peu la norme naturelle pour
en tout cas parler de pas mal de
structures de géométrique de
de toutes dimensions c'était une énorme
digressions tout ça pour vous dire que
ces espaces de caen dimension c'est
rentrer pour la classe et pour les
apprendre il faut faire de ce qu'on
appelle de la gr en lumière et j'ai une
série de vidéos sur un dida qui
partagent line up vous invite si vous
êtes motivés s'ils voulaient vraiment
apprendre les maths et pas juste être
exposé à la vulgarisation comme sur
scène ce soir je vous invite à essayer
de suivre cette série sur bandido et
j'espère que vous avez aimé cet épisode
et qu'il avait à peu près réussi à
suivre
si vous voulez en savoir plus allez
vraiment voir l'algérie linéaire comment
les vidéos que j'ai fait sur wii
c'est un petit peu difficile en
forcément c'est des matchs de niveau
supérieur
typiquement il faut une au niveau - bac
+ 1 à bac + 2 pour vraiment être à
l'aise avec ces notions ou en tout cas
le détail de ces notions je pense que
l'idée vraiment fascinante est
fondamental c'est surtout l'idée qui est
cette espèce de sémantique que l'on peut
construire et dans lequel en fait on
voit très bien les liens entre
utilisateurs et films et surtout on peut
utiliser cet espace pour effectuer des
prédictions et c'est quelque chose dont
on parlera plus au moins est ce que ça
va être un petit peu le thème d'une ces
mini série de trois vidéos notamment la
semaine prochaine on va parler de la
représentation vectorielle des mots
comment est-ce qu'on peut créer un
espace de sémantique pour représenter le
sens des mots c'est un truc à la fois
très récent et très fascinant si vous
avez aimé cet épisode pensait le lac et
à le commenter à le partager pensez à
vous abonner pour planquer futur
d'épisodes merci aux tipper cordon et
j'espère que vous serez là la prochaine
fois or trouver la bonne façon
d'orienter lé espace vectoriel pour bien
séparer les points ça revient en gros à
tourner l'espace pour l'aligner selon
des directions des plus intéressants et
ses directions et plus intéressante
ce sont en fait les vecteurs propre de
la matrice dit de covariance c'est à
dire la matrice qui étudie comment les
points sa ligne varie les uns par
rapport aux autres